public's reaction to last night's strip
shooting is something experts called
priming effect now we spoke to a unlv
psychologist today about this and how
dangerous it can be because of social
media
as human beings we are social creatures
unlv associate professor steven benning
says thursday night's shooting on the
las vegas strip caused an uproar on
social media however videos like this
showed the crowds more calm than usual
it is important in these kinds of
situations to
minimize the amount of panicked posting
that people might do benning says part
of the reason why people didn't seem to
panic at the mirage shooting was because
of the police swift presence and
reassuring public safety he says social
media has given a digital microphone to
everyone and that platform comes with a
moral responsibility it's the exposure
to a certain event without any awareness
of the connection it's called priming
effect it may be important for people
with large megaphones whether they be
traditional media social media
influencers whatever it might be
to
be careful with the information that
they disseminate
immediately before posting benning says
ask around if law enforcement is present
and what is known about the situation
live streaming could be dangerous
because it raises concern and fear to
the viewer
as in this case that happened in june
where metro police say bradley thompson
was arrested for throwing rocks through
glass at the mgm grand which caused
crowds on the strip to panic there is
the potential for that information to
have a wide range of viewers but that
may come at the cost of frightening a
large number of people
well benning adds that as technology
continues we are turning into the
espionage agent of the 70s dream where
information is freely available for many
sources sorting through it he says is
the challenge